grab your power ups and get ready to
teleport to A Whole New World
these Super Mario Brothers movie is
definitely a step in the right direction
from whatever the heck this was
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into the new Super Mario Brothers
movie Easter eggs from the games and
what major character could be coming in
the sequel so sit back and get ready for
an adventure let's ago the Super Mario
Brothers movie gets right into the
action with Bowser's attack on the ice
kingdom yes just like in the games there
are tons of Kingdoms which we can see
here on this map now the movie simply
refers to them with generic names like
Mushroom Kingdom jungle Kingdom and dark
lands this leaves three unknown kingdoms
which are most likely the sand Kingdom
since we see these upside down pyramids
from Super Mario Odyssey Yoshi's Island
which looks identical to the island from
Super Mario World 2 and the ice kingdom
but wait a minute why is the ice kingdom
covered in Flames that's because that no
good Bowser has taken it over from the
penguin King in his quest for the
Superstar a star of unimaginable power
that will surely impress Princess Peach
to whom he wants to marry right
alongside Bowser is his right hand Koopa
kamek who first made his appearance in
Super Mario World 2. he's voiced by
Kevin Michael Richards who you may
recognize as the voice of Dr Hibbert
Goro from Mortal Kombat or one of over
585 other films and TV shows seriously
this guy's a legend so kamik's magical
spells along with Bowser's flame breath
will crush the ice kingdom into
submission with all the poor Penguins to
be sacrificed at Bowser's wedding but
first Bowser must make his way to
Mushroom Kingdom and propose Bowser's
attack sets the stage for Mario and
Luigi who are just two normal
Italian-American plumbers trying to make
ends meet in Brooklyn New York in fact
the movie has their own commercial and a
website that actually works if you go to
smbplumbing.com it'll lead you to their
own site created by the brothers
themselves in fact the song during the
commercial is the same theme song from
the Mario Brothers Super Show from 1989.
[Music]
and the woman who calls for Mario and
Luigi's help is the original voice
actress for Princess Peach Mario and
Luigi spend a lot of their time at Pizza
punch out a local pizzeria named after
the Punch Out video game it's also where
we meet an old man by the name of
Giuseppe who's a voiced by a real Mario
voice actor Charles martinet who also
voices Mario's dad in the movie he's
playing an arcade game called Jumpman
which was the original name for Mario in
Donkey Kong we also get a brief look at
spike a rival plumber who first appeared
in 1985 as a wrecking crew and if you go
to smbplumbing.com you can actually see
a user by the name of spike is cool
who's left a one star review with the
testimonial saying the brothers used to
work for him until they started their
own business now I plan on doing another
video comparing this movie to the 1993
live action version which also has a
character named Spike in it so if you
haven't already make sure you're
subscribed so you can watch out for that
as we get a cool 2D romp through a
construction site we can make out Castle
burger which looks awfully a lot like
those castles at the end stages in the
original Mario game but it's at home
where we find the core of Mario's story
and his character Arc he feels like no
one in his life takes him seriously
especially his father to him everyone
thinks he's small they make fun of his
commercial his trademark white gloves
and think he's bringing down his little
brother Luigi if only something huge
could happen to prove to his family he's
not the failure everyone thinks he is
but before he gets a chance to prove
himself there are some fun little Easter
eggs in his room like a poster of an
f-zero racer a model R wing fighter from
Star Fox and he's playing Kid Icarus on
the NES Mario it's 2023 there are other
games out there so Mario gets his big
chance to prove himself when a huge pipe
bursts in Brooklyn on the news is Mayor
Pauline Pauline was the original Damsel
in Distress from Donkey Kong and the
mayor of New donk City in Odyssey so
Mario takes Luigi to save the day and if
you look closely in the background
you'll notice a restaurant called Shas
Canard which is French for duck hunt and
it even has the same logo to stop the
water they must Venture into the sewers
to release the pressure valve and in the
background you can make out a sign that
says level 1-2 which is the first sewer
level in Super Mario Brothers but soon
Mario is sucked into an interdimensional
portal and is split from his brother
poor Luigi ends up in the dark lands and
Mario in Mushroom Kingdom there he meets
toad voiced by Keegan Michael Key who
will take him to meet the princess who
just might know where his brother is
Toad was first featured in the original
Super Mario Brothers game in 1985. Luigi
however is not so lucky where he was
spit out in the dark lands where he
encounters a ghastly group of skeleton
Koopas who first made their appearance
in Super Mario Brothers 3 and they've
been a staple throughout the franchise
ever since it's kind of fitting Luigi
gets sent to This creepy location
considering his ghost hunting skills in
Luigi's Mansion but it's actually a
group of shy guys who NAB Luigi and take
him to Bowser's Lair shy guys were first
introduced in Super Mario Brothers 2.
now the detail put into toe town is
absolutely stunning from toads
collecting coins at crazy cap store from
Super Mario Odyssey and an antique shop
holding items such as a hammer bro
hammer there's a dragon coin which
features Yoshi various keys p-switches
and more the whole town is connected via
these multi-colored pipes which lead
Mario to Peach's castle a castle that
looks almost identical to the one found
in Super Mario 64. complete with that
stained glass window within the castle
you can see these huge murals on the
wall just like those that transport
Mario to various Worlds the Toads have
convened a sort of war council to
discuss what to do about Bowser's
Advance into the ice kingdom and it's
here we get our first look at Princess
Peach voiced by Anya Taylor Joy she's an
assertive and stalwart defender of her
people but there's one thing that sets
her apart from all the others she looks
to be human so when Mario sneaks his way
in seeking her help she's is happy just
to see someone who looks like her you
see Princess Peach in the movie doesn't
know her real family she appeared
through one of these pipes as a child
and was raised by the Toads to become
their leader in the games Peach has a
father named the Mushroom King or King
Toadstool but he's only mentioned
briefly in the Super Mario Brothers
instruction booklet and some obscure
Mario manga but if Mario is going to
join Peach on this Quest he must first
complete Peach's training course which
has tons of mechanical piranha bullet
bills and moving platforms found in the
games and I love the irony that Mario
hates eating mushrooms one of the most
common power-ups in the game it's here
we find out that Mario has been in his
small form the entire time handsome
being shorter than Peach but as soon as
he eats one of these red mushrooms he
Powers up and becomes taller than her
even though Mario never successfully
completes the course Peach sees that he
has the heart to take Bowser on which
she'll later say is the toad Kingdom's
greatest asset back at Bowser's Lair the
Koopas celebrate their Victory and we
get to see Bob bombs Goombas and these
little guys that Bowser forgets spinies
Bowser lets them know if Princess Peach
does not agree to marry him then he will
destroy the Mushroom Kingdom once and
for all and in an unforgettable moment
he sings a song playing on his Ludwig
von Koopa piano named after the eldest
Koopaling in the Super Mario Brothers
game and a play on Ludwig van Beethoven
we get to see some cool Landscapes like
the sand Kingdom and Yoshi's Island but
it's here among a field filled with
flame flowers try saying that 10 times
fast that Mario divulges to Peach that
he's never been away from his brother
this long in his life he's usually been
around to protect him as seen in a very
cool flashback where we see baby Luigi
and Mario who look like the versions
found in Super Mario World 2. because
Mario saw Luigi sucked into the dark
land they believe he's been picked up by
Bowser and that's exactly where he is
imprisoned alongside king penguin and
this adorable existentialist star named
lumily lumily is a Luma shop vendor from
Super Mario Galaxy Peach Mario and Toad
are on their way to Jungle Kingdom now I
know a lot of you want to say Donkey
Kong Country but it's never actually
referred to that in the film but
honestly I want to call it that too the
film does a great job integrating
aspects of Mario Kart allowing us to
take in these amazing visuals they've
come to ask for help in finding Bowser
but their leader Cranky Kong won't give
it to them that easily fun fact Cranky
Kong was first seen in Donkey Kong
Country but it's set in various pieces
of official media that Cranky Kong is
actually the original Donkey from the
Donkey Kong game just in older form if
Mario can defeat Donkey Kong voiced by
Seth Rogen then Peach can have his army
and I love how Donkey Kong comes out to
the Donkey Kong rap the iconic song
first featured in Donkey Kong 64.
in the crowd we briefly get to see
Swanky Dixie and Diddy Kong while Mario
first gets his butt handed to him Mario
eventually gains the upper hand when
obtaining a super Bell power-up which
transforms him into Cat Mario and
ability that first made its appearance
in Super Mario 3D World The increased
agility allows him to defeat this
sluggish Donkey Kong and win cranky
Kong's Army meanwhile Bowser is in his
wedding attire and rehearses asking
Peach to marry him we've seen Bowser in
this attire in Super Mario Odyssey in
order to catch up to Bowser whoever the
Gang has to travel on the iconic Rainbow
Road on their go-karts this is honestly
one of the coolest parts of the movie
and it feels it got a lot of inspiration
from Mad Max with giant explosions and
non-stop action unfortunately Mario and
Donkey Kong are separated from Peach in
the Army the Army is captured by
Bowser's flying Koopas Peach escapes to
Mushroom Kingdom and Donkey Kong and
Mario fall into the ocean where they're
eaten by a mahre these giant sea
creatures that first appeared in Super
Mario 64. luckily Donkey Kong and Mario
are able to escape flying out of the ma
Ray's mouth on Donkey Kong's cart but
they are late as Bowser's Army has
already descended on toe town and the
wedding is underway Peach has agreed to
marry Bowser are in exchange for leaving
the Toads alone unfortunately Bowser's
word is about as good as my
ex-girlfriends and in celebration of
their marriage he plans to execute all
the prisoners thankfully Donkey Kong and
Mario bash their way to save Peach but
honestly she doesn't need much saving
she uses a freeze power-up to fight
Bowser but in the melee ends up
exploding King Bob om the first boss of
Mario 64. Mario grabs a power up which
transforms him into Tanuki Mario Tanuki
are a type of raccoon dog found in Japan
and this power first appeared in Super
Mario Brothers 3. it allows him to force
this giant Bullet Bill which Bowser
Unleashed from his volcano and detonate
it through the pipe that connects our
worlds the explosion is so huge that it
causes all the characters from Mushroom
Kingdom to be transported to our world
now Mario is knocked out by Bowser into
ironically the punch out Pizzeria and
it's here Mario has to make a big
decision does he have the strength to
carry on and fight an enemy who's far
more powerful than him and just at that
moment the commercial plays with him and
his brother giving him that much needed
boost to fight for those he loves at the
same time Bowser's superstar has fallen
into the middle of the street leaving it
free for capture but it's Luigi who
comes in and saves Mario this time using
a sewer great to fend off Bowser's flame
Mario and Luigi dashed toward the
Superstar and both of them gain its
power up just like in the game this star
gives them invincibility allowing them
to defeat Bowser Peach even forces him
to eat a blue mushroom which turns him
into a small Bowser now at the end of
the movie we see Bowser is held prisoner
in this small form at Peach's castle but
if we know anything about Bowser we know
he won't be in there for long Mario's
dad comes out telling him that he's
amazing Mario has proven to him and the
people of Brooklyn that he isn't a
screw-up completing his character Arc
this movie and it looks as though Mario
now lives in the Mushroom Kingdom as we
see him wake up there on his way to his
job he also has way better control over
these pipes so I'm guessing he can
easily transport himself from our world
of Mushroom Kingdom and potentially
countless other places leaving the
potential for a sequel all the more
likely now there is a post-credits scene
that hints at this other than lumily
playing the saxophone and seeing Bowser
imprisoned both of which don't give us
any clues the final scene takes us back
to the Brooklyn sewers where a Yoshi egg
can be seen it's quite likely that this
egg is the same egg that was left as a
wedding gift for Bowser and Peach's
wedding unfortunately that clip isn't
available but if you look closely at the
gift table you'll see a green Yoshi egg
that likely got sucked into our world
during the explosion so if there's a
Super Mario Brothers movie too expect
Yoshi to play a large role just like he
did in Super Mario World 2. but I want
to hear what you thought about the Super
Mario Brothers movie in the comments
below thanks for watching and be sure to
like And subscribe for more bad takes
you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember Luigi
foreign